what's going on guys it's back-to-school
month and that means here at screen
junkies we are continuing to strive to
educate about film that's why today
we're bringing you the best movies
you've never seen oh and if you have
seen them it means you're a true screen
junkie okay I know some of you gonna be
screaming at your computer hey I've seen
that relax it's all good and we've got a
couple of true cinema fans a couple huge
movie fans to talk about it with first
you know them you love them dan the man
the movie fights champion Merle thank
you how thank you very glad to be here
and uh this gentleman is visiting us for
the first time you can find his work on
cinema blend welcome Eric Eisenberg nice
have and I'm glad to be here it's great
oh well Eric it's great to have you so
when we put together our list of films
that aren't as common aren't as popular
some hidden gems that not everyone is
seen we chose some deeper cuts yeah yeah
but not like the goal is it to be like
super obscure like we're not gonna go
like deep into the filmography of some
polish director that you've never heard
of to find you know it's like no these
are the battleship potemkin that's a
great movie yeah is that like great
movies that you should see yeah these
are all like probably more or less
mainstream movies that I think for
whatever reason went kind of under the
radar last over I've been lost a time
for whatever or I even have aged well
enough that suddenly they weren't really
that great when they first came out but
now like they're spectacular yeah yeah
Dan I'd love to start with you what's a
movie that you wanted to talk about
well my first recommendation it's movie
called shattered glass came out in 2003
don't go anywhere it stars him
Christensen don't guy don't go anywhere
some people might find that to be a deal
break so a lot of people only know him
from the prequels and they're like Oh
Hayden Christensen is a terrible actor
every time somebody says that I say
watch shattered glass he is great in
this movie it's about a journalist named
Stephen glass who worked her story had
based on a true story he essentially
fabricated entire stories out of thin
air and it's about the kind of
unraveling of his fabrications not a
criminal
it's a fantastic movie Hayden
Christensen is great in that I'm not
saying it makes up for how bad he was
equals are and some of other movies but
he is fantastic is great
thank you Dan for starting us off Eric
talked to us about a film that you'd
like to share honestly I'm gonna start
by talking about whenever I'm kind of
asked this question whenever I'm kind of
posed the idea of the best movie
nobody's ever seen this is always the
one that I go to it's called the last
seduction it's this movie by Jon Dahl
you know mid-90s it saw this incredible
neo-noir like story of this woman who is
just like just savage [ __ ] like this is
like unbelievably hardcore character
thank you can also be very effective you
leave I'm a huge old-school Nora fan and
this kid she's with this and a people
like Barbara Stanwyck yes some of the
tough Dame's of the 1950's in this yeah
it's just super hardcore in every single
move and it's all so twisty and turny as
you'd imagine and it's um for sure dan
throw another one at us one of the
greatest directors I think of all time
was Sidney Lumet he did 12 Angry Men he
did Network he's done so many amazing
movies his last movie was made in 2007
it was called before the devil knows
you're dead
and I think it is fantastic it stars
Philip Seymour Hoffman who is amazing in
this movie and Ethan Hawke our brothers
Philip Seymour Hoffman is kind of a
dirty dealing businessman Ethan Hawke is
kind of the Nair do well believe this is
you it's talking I believe it so it's
safe nobody gets hurt everybody wins
it's perfect the great thing but this
movie is it unfolds kind of in layers so
you know things and then it goes back in
time and tells you that not money or
night is very handsome linear so I don't
want to go too much into the plot of it
it involves a robbery that goes wrong
you see things for perspective and then
it'll rewind itself and show you the
same thing from a different perspective
and it's not until the end of the movie
that you really get all the pieces of
the story and you see what's happening
and I think it is an amazing movie I'm
shocked that it didn't have any Oscar
buzz really it has your attention
whatsoever I think for me it's my
personal favorite performance that
Philip Seymour Hoffman ever did and when
she is all no no no nobody saw you at
the hell I love him in this movie and I
think that it
Sidney Lumet's last movie I think it's
also one of his best it seems we're on a
little bit of a crime kick here I'm
gonna keep it going sure I'm in the
wayback machine and talk about a movie
from 1956 not the first movie but a very
early Stanley Kubrick film called the
killing yeah this movie is about a race
track robbery that surprised kind of
Goza ass over teakettle goes wrong and
it stars sterling Hayden who's one of
the Great War actors of the 1950's this
movie early Stanley Kubrick there's so
much to love about it well another great
early Kubrick is passive glory which
stars the same star as my next movie
which was made 1951 by another great
director Billy Wilder he's made several
of my favorite films this star Kirk
Douglas
it's called ace in the hole this is a
movie that a lot of people thought was
lost forever it was kind of rediscovered
and when it was found again people said
like this is like yeah wait a minute
this is an incredible movie it starts
Kirk Douglas is this kind of washed-up
reporter he literally just kind of
breaks down in this dusty desert town
and a guy gets trapped in a mine and
it's about this reporter who is
manipulating the situation kind of
slowing down the rescue efforts and he
turns this into a national event
literally a carnival and the alternate
title for the film is the big carnival
carnival and basically people just flock
and it just becomes like the guy in the
mine is secondary to just the scene
that's happening and it is so relevant
now to exactly the way the media works
today which is that the story is
secondary
it's everything surrounding it and and
the way that the story progresses with
the fleeting attention of the public and
the way that you know you're a hero
today and tomorrow you're yesterday's
news I go on home is over it's amazing
how this movie that was made so long ago
and was lost forever is as relevant
maybe more relevant today than it was
when it was made Eric let's hear another
one from you buddy I'll shoot uh kind of
a more controversial one be mostly
because of the source material it's a
Bret Easton Ellis adaptation obviously
that's going to immediately turn some
people off some people just aren't going
to deal with it but I'm going to talk
about
of attraction because it is the second
movie from director roger avery also his
last movie he hasn't made any sense
which I find really unfortunate because
while its content is again controversial
it's also completely unflinching
unapologetic it is deeply affecting but
also is just more importantly just Avery
has such an incredible sense of point of
view and perspective
yeah I agree like this is a movie that
hit when I was I think a freshman in
college and I was hugely impressed by
this movie just from a technical
standpoint I remember there's a scene
with Shannyn Sossamon and james van der
beek where they start on opposite sides
of cities let's create from that is
completely first-person based and you're
following them in real-time and as it
progresses you realize by the end they
end up facing each other in the same in
a hallway in front of the same bulletin
board and I just remember just
stylistically is such an interesting way
to and talking directly to the kids like
they're talking directly to camera at
split-screen and then of course it
unfolds eventually and like it's Avery
ever comes around stylist it like Avery
is incredibly stylistic filmmaker it's
really shame yes I mean yeah Sullivan's
Travels such a great Sullivan's Travels
is about this mainstream big-time movie
director who wants to make the great
American tragedy but he says to himself
before I can do that I need to
experience real tragedy so he decides to
kind of essentially become a hobo he
rides the rails and wants to feel real
hardship and he has no idea what he's in
for and if you need an endorsement I
mean this is a movie that influenced the
Coen brothers hugely if you watch Oprah
the brother art that literally came from
that film yeah yeah oh brother where art
thou Coen Brothers film takes its name
from that's the name of the film that
the director wants to make I want to
make o brother where art thou I'll tell
you what I'm gonna do first
going down to wardrobe and get some old
clothes some old shoes hmm and I'm gonna
start off with 10 cents in my pocket huh
I don't know where I'm going but I'm not
coming back till I know what trouble is
what there's a story now whether this is
true or not but I think it is true that
way back I think in 1997 when the in
America Film Institute put their first
list of the 100 greatest movies ever
made out there's a story that Steven
Spielberg called them and said can you
please take jaws or Raiders off this
list and put solvent Wow
yeah yeah yeah flu intial I'd never
heard the directors yeah Wow Dan want to
throw another one our way there's a
movie 1996 that came out directed by Tom
Hanks it's called that thing you do this
is a movie that what it was not a big
hit when it came out I don't even
theaters that I saw this a few times
I've had him on VHS I've had in a DVD
I've had in a blu-ray I've had it on
every format you could have it on it's
just joyful it's it's about this band in
Pennsylvania this garage band
essentially back in the 60s and they
write a song called that thing you do
and they become they're called the
wonders and they become one-hit wonder
the o-neders spelled with the one suck
on the o-neders
go go go go go go go it's just so much
fun and it's just like if you just want
to have a great time if you want to feel
like you just saw something that's very
pure there's not an ounce of cynicism in
that movie it's just about these kids
that are rock stars overnight and it's
just a really classic Hollywood story
nice
thanks for uplifting because we talked
about a lot of interests crying noises
yeah uh Eric Doyle is right back into
darkness because the next one I want to
talk about is a Jurgis lanthanum oats
dog tooth it's a Greek film that came
out a couple years ago I was recently
just thinking about honestly because he
just put out a new film called the
lobster with the best monster which is
fantastic is unbelievably great and if
but it's also just an extension of his
the director style which is incredibly
goddamn weird just because what this
movie is is it's about this family they
literally know they don't have any names
its mother father older sister younger
sister and brother living in complete
isolation living this kind of fenced off
compound and essentially their father
has kind of completely manipulated their
reality like he's completely changed
language he convinces everyone that the
stray cat that hanging out their
backyard has killed their brother and
it's like the savage beast is that is
going to rip them apart if they try and
escape or the forces Pathan and a plasma
son of dopey civilian understand given
the immense it's incredibly great and
honestly it has a very sci-fi quality to
it and just that it feels like it could
just exist on another planet this next
one is from Robert Altman one of the
great maverick directors of the 1970s
what a filmography Robert Altman has
this is a 1992 film called the player so
good not the greatest Hollywood movies
ever yeah one of the greatest Hollywood
movies ever it's a Hollywood noir that
talks about just the backstabbing the
intrigue the lies that make this town go
round and round Tim Robbins is amazing
in this film if you want to see a modern
noir that really makes a statement about
that movie industry the player it's
fantastic film and a very layered movie
there's a point where without giving too
much weight he's kind of on the run from
something and if even if you listen the
way that Altman staggers because he's
always that overlapping dialogue in his
movies but as he's kind of sweating it
out like is he gonna get discovered all
these characters start coming up to me
like saying Griffen Griffen Griffen
Griffen and liked it slowly start
speeding up even if you listen to the
music the way Altman does the music the
music embedded and it has people going
Griffen Griffen Griffen Griffen so it's
like this idea of the walls closing in
yeah it's such a great movie for sure
dan oh my last one is from 1999 which by
the way was a amazing year for cinema
there's a movie come out 2099 that
people don't talk about as much it's
called payback it stars Mel Gibson he
plays this kind of hitman named Porter
and it's very simple story he gets
betrayed by his best friend and he wants
his money back his best friend steals
some money that they left together back
he wants payback and so the entire movie
is just him working his way up the
levels of this organization this crime
organization and every level has a great
actor one level is William Devane who's
amazing and the next level is James
Coburn who's a great actor so is it like
a video game with a boss on each leg and
and there's a joke about the fact that
like he he the amount of money that he
wants back is very small it's like
$7,000 or $7,000 they keep saying like
he wants to $700,000 Wang's like no it's
like you doing all this for seven like
are you crazy and is like this is it's
about it's the whole thing is just about
it's the Pretz them it's just the
premise of it he just he's just on
general principle he will not stand it's
not onion man that's just mean that's
mean man this movie has a director's cut
that I actually think is inferior to the
original version the final version is a
crime story but it's very playful and
very much a payback movie and Mel Gibson
is kind of like this swaggering kind of
antihero yeah and it's a really good
time the director's cut is much darker
it takes away a lot of that humor and
the playfulness and I actually think the
theatrical version it's a case where
maybe the studio or whoever was right
yeah and I think that the theatrical
version is superior to the one of the
rare occasion rare awesome thanks Dan
Eric well my last race I'm going to kind
of break the rules a little bit because
technically my last pick is a movie that
a lot of people had it's a two movies
that a lot of people have seen but it's
together one movie that note next to
nobody is saying we just Kill Bill the
whole bloody affair which I personally
only said I've seen every movie as I
mentioned I've seen multiple times this
one I've only seen once because I've
only been able to see it once um the big
difference between it I mean those who
are familiar with Tarantino's Kill Bill
it's essentially what it's taking both
movies and putting into one and while
isn't all that much that's really I have
taken there aren't many new scenes or
many scenes taken out but the way that
it's put together is just so it changes
the film and in such a significant way
specifically the biggest move is that
obviously in Kill Bill volume 1 the big
twist is the reveal that the bride's
daughter is still alive that's not in
the whole bloody affair you don't
actually get that twist until she is
actually face to face with her daughter
oh and that comes across in such a more
significant way because you're going to
this entire movie obviously if you've
seen the film you kind of already know
it but you going through some other
movie sheets it has this mentality where
it's just like she thinks that
everything has been taken away from her
and then all of a sudden it's right
there it's just such a completely
different experience within that and
it's just a completely different read
for the film and it works incredibly
well of course it also has the hallmark
of not having the black-and-white light
against the crazy 88 and like not only
is it not black and white it is longer
it is crazy it is like unbleached ly
they cut like it's very easy to annotate
battle it's unreal the other part about
it is that the movies are still
separated there is an intermission in
between it all flows better but at the
same time there is the separation so you
still get the quality of Kill Bill
volume 1 and volume two being completely
disparate film genre wise and it just it
works so incredibly well and their Lord
somebody put this movie out Wow uh you
know what I think I have some viewing I
have some homework to do now I'm excited
to dive in a couple of those films that
I have not seen how many of the films
that we mentioned have you seen what are
you most excited about what's your kind
of hidden gem that not a lot of people
know let us know in the comments section
below
we want to know I got to thank my
awesome panel guys that was an enriching
conversation I feel I feel like more of
a cine esteem up after talking to you
guys Dan Merle always great to have you
buddy
thanks for having me and Eric Eisenberg
thank you for your maiden voyage higher
on screen Johnny funds this is fantastic
yeah thank you for having me and thank
you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter bye bye from John fab
the guy who went from playing Mike in
swingers to becoming one of today's best
directors - one of the worst - one of
the best again unum comes the year's
best film about talking animals you must
be the very worst wolf I'm a machine
which is really saying something because
there's been like 10 of them already and
the years not even done yet
the Jungle Book